Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor Greene has appeared
on conspiracy theorist Alex Jones Infowars,
and she wants to make it known that she is
not crazy.
She says it bothers her to be treated like
she's a crazy person.
This is all starting to be beyond parody.
Let's take a listen to Marjorie Taylor Greene.
Speaker 6: And it just bothers me so much.
They treat me as if I'm some kind of crazy
person, like I have three horns coming out
of my head.
But what they don't understand is they're
the ones that are crazy, right?
Speaker 1: Everybody else is crazy.
She's not.
Everything she does is completely normal.
And by the way, she says this with an info.
More sign behind her, which is a choice to
do that.
And she seems unable to realize that Alex
Jones is crazy.
It's very similar to Mike Lindell.
Claiming to have evidence that is going to
put 300 million people behind bars and then
saying everybody else is crazy because they
don't realize the evidence is so obvious at
a certain point, a non crazy person and I
get that these I'm not I'm not literally using
these terms.
I'm not stigmatizing mental illness, but wacky.
Maybe we use wacky or disconnected from reality
at a certain point, a person who's connected
to reality would realize when you say you
have evidence to imprison 300 million people
for their role in the 2020 election, you would
realize I'm the wacky one, right?
And it's the exact same thing, with Marjorie
Taylor Greene just completely disconnected
from her own reality that she's saying outrageous
things that no serious sane person could possibly
believe.
She also is continuing to say them, even as
she claims to be not crazy at an event in
Texas over the weekend, which we talked about
earlier earlier in the week.
She says, you know, AOC was a bartender, so
she's not smart.
Speaker 6: OK.
Where is that energy going to be created?
Your solar and wind?
Don't you know?
Come on, AOC, so much smarter than all of
us, she was a bartender, right?
Right.
You silly conservative Republicans, you probably
have small businesses and things like that.
Shame on you, independent people that know
how to balance a checkbook right now.
Speaker 1: In all seriousness, people can
be smart coming from all walks of life.
I know people who have every type of job you
could imagine, and they are smart people,
OK?
But is Marjorie Taylor Greene's background
really anything to no one prove her intelligence
and number two to put her in a position to
make fun of other people's work backgrounds
like Marjorie Taylor, Greene's dad gave her
and her husband his general contracting company.
Oh, OK, wow.
Well, so she ran a business well, the Atlanta
Journal-Constitution investigated, and they
determined she has had no significant presence
at the company whatsoever, so she sort of
didn't really run the company.
Her dad gave her.
She then started CrossFit training and ended
up founding a CrossFit gym.
And if we all wanted to play the game that
she's playing, we could say, Well, I'm sure
Marjorie Taylor Greene is smart.
I mean, she had a CrossFit gym, right?
It's sort of like neither here nor there,
but we can only be led to believe that Marjorie
Taylor Greene thinks bartenders aren't intelligent,
but CrossFit people are.
Bartenders aren't qualified to be members
of Congress, but CrossFit gym owners are.
And in reality, what we need are measures
like Can you think critically, do your beliefs
follow from the evidence?
Do you have a normal level of empathy with
which you can understand situations that other
people are in?
And then the last thing I'll say about this
also is, you know, they they claim that they
are about the working people.
They are against the so-called elites now,
half the time when they mean elites, they
just mean Jews.
And it's an anti-Semitic cover, like when
they say globalists, you know, you guys understand
that these are often coded words now.
But if you're for the middle class, if you're
for the working man and woman, then why would
it be disqualifying that?
AOC was a bartender, and so of course, their
principle that they are for the little guy
falls apart very quickly through their own
elitism that is very clearly displayed in
this way.
Even though Marjorie Taylor Greene has really
nothing in her background that would make
her feel like an elite by her own standards,
and it's pathetic and it's disgusting, and
we should remember their stated principles
are abandoned as soon as they want to make
a point against one of their political enemies.